olympian who turned back on flag during
anthem says she feels set up by u.s
track and field oh i saw this gwen berry
turned away from the flag while the
anthem played
she later draped a t-shirt that said
activist athlete
um yeah
athletes can do whatever they want you
know i think
we definitely have been through a time
where
we got used to as a country for a long
time the athletes being happy to
represent the country they were
in represent america
um it's so funny
there's a lot of people who are like
[ __ ] america but
america is just a society that's all it
is
and there's a lot of people out there
um who act like society like it's all
some big plan against them
it's just society you know
uh the activist athlete thing i think
some of it gets a little bit old
you know it's like look everybody people
have already done it
just play your sport
that's kind of how i feel a little bit i
also feel like she can do whatever she
wants
i feel like she'll just turn a lot of
people off
some companies or something will come
along and use her to
be a voice for them to get some product
pushed across
and that'll be that
you know now though it's a lot more
pressure if she doesn't even win
she got third place
third place yes it's great it's still
the olympics
but let's get first place
you didn't even beat two other countries
okay
you're like my country sucks like uh
it would have been better if you'd
gotten first your country would be
better
so i don't know i just i'm not
i'm from the time where man it would
have been anything to be able to perform
for the u.s this isn't my country it
doesn't respect
my views it's just a group of people
trying their best that's all the country
is
and she just wants to make it about her
that that's what i think it is
and that's just more the society goes
back to the lady at the freaking
with the signage at the tour de france
she just wants to make it about her
you know it's just like how can i make
this about me
and in some ways it's just kind of the
the generations that we're in
right now we want to have our own
platform
oh this is who i am but this is also how
i feel
um i mean i do it here on on this
but there is an interesting thing
because we long have expected athletes
just to be an athlete like you're at
your job
but i do feel like it's kind of i feel
like it's disgraceful
to america that's what i feel like i
feel like yes you can do it
um but there's just a lot of people
there's no gratitude for where we are
you know the national anthem upset her
it was hot out there i get it
some of those things look it's too hot
maybe they should have put them under a
thing she would have been more
comfortable
i was thinking about what i should do
barry added eventually i just stayed
there and just swayed i put my shirt
over my head it was real disrespectful
i knew they did that on purpose but
it'll be all right i'll see what's up
i see what's up yeah
look i've had this mentality people are
out to get me it's all about me
um i don't know i think get first
get first and then we'll talk that's
kind of how i feel on it
but it makes me not want to cheer for
her i'm an american
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one